with all might seemingly about to die in
the mha manga who will be the new symbol
of peace all my attest to all for one
that even if one person's light goes out
another person can inherit that light
and use it to keep Illuminating the
darkness the light of one for all was
extinguished with an all might because
he transferred The Quirk to Deku and
that same light now shines within Deku
but symbolically all might is saying
that he knows that he's probably about
to die but even if he does the next
generation of Heroes will carry on his
light members of the next generation
will become the new symbols of peace all
might has gone out of his way to pay
respects to all of his students and
their abilities which means that the new
symbol of peace will not be just one
person not even Deku it will be all the
students together the entire new
generation of Heroes will be the new
symbol of peace for more energy content
subscribe to anime outpro right now